i'm going to go full spoilers with you
do not worry we are going to save this
until after the season is available
the first specific moment i wanted to
ask you about is is it safe to assume
that the conversation in episode four
about yasgar's song and the timelines
was a playful jab at your own show
yes of course um also we had the writers
and i had so many different pitches for
those lines we really struggled with
what to choose um you know i think part
of the fun of the witcher is that it
does poke fun of itself you know and
that's what makes it different than a
lot of other fantasy shows there is a
tongue in cheekness to how we tell our
stories and certainly a self-awareness i
came out of season one knowing very much
what people liked what they didn't like
so to be able to have yaskir uh write
this song um and then to be able to hear
this doc guards uh critiques of it it
was an amazing amazing thing to put in
there i got the biggest kick out of that
and i respect it quite a bit
so
i also wanted to ask you what it was
like coming up with that scene where
geralt essentially turns triss down
because i'm not someone who's read the
books or played the games yet at least
but the conversation that i've heard
about from fans most is the whole yen
versus triss thing so when that moment
came up it made me wonder you know what
was it like for you figuring out how to
best approach a moment like that in in
tone but also the specific way that tris
conveys interest because i like i could
feel the romantic tension there but
perhaps it could also be interpreted as
somewhat platonic
yes so i think the romantic intention is
definitely there the thing that was
important to me um which we took
directly from the books is that tris
asks carol to spend the night with her
and in the books he actually says yes
once she says it just just basically lay
with me you know nothing is going to
happen
um and henry felt very very strongly
that when we were playing this scene he
still believed that his one true love
jennifer wengerberg was um dead he was
still mourning her and so he didn't
actually want to go that extra step and
have them have any intimacy whatsoever
which i respect it i do think that that
feels true to our girl character
what i wanted to make sure of though is
that it didn't make triss
looked like she was just out to get a
guy that she knew she couldn't get and
one of the other things that we went
back to the book for was her response to
him on the b side of that sort of
rejection if you will where she's saying
to him i realized that all i want to do
is feel alive again to have a feeling
and it doesn't matter that you rejected
me i actually know now that i have this
potential for um
for intimacy again i have this potential
to have these feelings and to me it is
like the the biggest sort of power
moment for tris and we get to keep
playing that in future seasons as well
which is she is sort of owning herself
again and it's i think it was an
incredible thing for her character as
well it's a very beautiful moment i
liked it quite a bit so again i haven't
read the book so i hope my research does
not fail me on this but
yen losing her powers that that's your
creation right
yes that is our creation so in the books
um in blood valves specifically
we we leave yen having been injured in
the battle of sadden and you don't
really hear that much about her and then
suddenly geralt writes her letters
saying i need your help to train siri
and she shows up again
um and i knew that our audiences would
not be uh content with that because it
would really feel like she was just
waiting on the sidelines to be called
back into action um and so we did want
to craft a story of her uh of her own in
the books she's blinded at sadden and we
actually make several references to
being blind for yennefer this season but
we talked about what is the more um
potent blindness that she could have
what would yennifer's walking through
the world in darkness look like and to
us you know to the writer's room that
was to walk in a world without magic and
it felt like such an easy one to one
that we could dramatize a lot more and
and we love her storyline this season
what an effective way to make that
character grow too and also what an
effective way in general based on
everything you're saying and everything
that i've experienced in the show thus
far to get people who have not
experienced the source material to be
able to enjoy your show but inspire them
to want to see more and read more so
very their job well done in that respect
um of all the characters in season two
was there any one with a story arc that
was particularly challenging for you to
crack
you know vestimir was actually an
interesting one to crack um also now one
of my favorites you know in the books um
vessemer is really curmudgeonly um
incredibly so and yet we knew that we
wanted to bring another side of him uh
to the forefront especially because in
our story siri is really trying to
figure out her place in the world and
she's trying to figure out who she can
trust
and to me it was important that vessemer
have a more empathetic side so that siri
could begin to
to want to be around him and to be
inspired by what he's trying to do in
the world so we went through a lot of
different versions the very first
versions of his story he was very gruff
and very sort of to the point and we
started to peel those layers back and
bring out what i would call a little bit
more of the grandfatherly side in in
vesamir while also still keeping him um
you know there's a detachment to him you
can tell that he's afraid of being hurt
again so i would say that story probably
went through the most changes but i'm so
so thrilled of where it ended up and
honestly what cambodia brought to it
as you should be before they kicked me
out of here i know uh before season one
was even released you had mentioned that
you had a seven season plan for the show
so how has the show's success and then
also maybe new things that you've
discovered about the story along the way
impacted that initial plan
um i love that i love that seven seasons
became the thing that we go to because i
think also at one point i said something
that i would go for like 20 seasons and
i'm glad that no one actually expects me
to have 20 seasons i would be
dead by that um you know i do think that
my my utmost goal and the reason i
started with seven years is because i
wanted to
stay
true to the books i don't feel the need
for our story to go beyond where the
books go i think andrew sabkovsky the
writer he had a natural end in mind now
actually since we started the show he
has released more books so we'll have to
see how that fits into it but i also
think i'm not in a rush to get through
these stories you know we we
approximately do a book a season but we
also make sure that the stories from
that book are best in that season of our
television show so sometimes we move
those chess pieces around a little bit
there's a big story from blood valves
that we're gonna do in season three for
instance or there was a short story that
we couldn't fit in season one so we put
it in season two we try to be pretty
flexible with that
all righty i'm gonna leave you with that
next time i see you i'm gonna have read
the books
really inspired me and i've gotten very
into the world in the lore and now i
need more wonderful wonderful big
congrats to you and thanks so much for
talking to us today
you